hola andrés gracias por la invitación
básicamente observo los
elementos que
dan pie a esta crisis energética en
europa la primera de ellas tiene que ver
con la recuperación económica la rápida
recuperación económica y con la
imposibilidad de la oferta en el
suministro para poder satisfacer la el
incremento de la demanda energética que
se que se ha motivado por la
recuperación energética en un segundo
tiempo también observó que hay
temas de cortes de electricidad en
europa motivados por eventos
meteorológicos
pero más allá de estos dos elementos que
te comento en el fondo hay un tema
relacionado con la crisis climática los
cambios en las temperaturas han hecho
que europa registrará un invierno
particularmente frío y que el verano
también fuera particularmente caluroso
lo que ha incrementado la demanda de los
energéticos esto andrés es lo que
explica el incremento de los energéticos
en el continente europeo
ahora cuál es el impacto de esta crisis
más allá de las fronteras europeas habrá
repercusiones para américa por ejemplo
desde luego me gustaría empezar
comentando por ejemplo que american de
este bank of america merrill lynch ha
señalado que el golpe para los europeos
será de 500 dólares en gastos en el año
esto eso se tendrán que gastar 500 euros
más en el año por el incremento en las
tarifas energéticas y en términos
globales el impacto se espera también
particularmente claro para todo el mundo
tomando en cuenta que el aumento en los
energéticos en las tarifas eléctricas
puede socavar puede afectar la
recuperación económica generando
complicaciones para los países sobre
todo para las economías emergentes y de
manera particular también hay un tema
relacionado con la inflación andrés en
la medida en que se registran tarifas
eléctricas y precios de los energéticos
altos esto será un tema que deberán
quedar los gobiernos para no afectar a
los ciudadanos y para que la inflación
en los países a nivel global no afecte
como repito el crecimiento
bueno y en otras aristas de este tema
rusia niega que use el gas como un arma
pero al mismo tiempo busca incrementar
sus ventas de gas con el north stream 2
es europa demasiado dependiente de rusia
como como analiza el rol de moscú en
esta crisis desde luego es muy
interesante esta reflexión que se ha
dado en torno al suministro de gas ruso
a unión a la unión europea en este
sentido es cierto que la unión europea
depende en buena medida del gas natural
de rusia pero hay que recordar también
por otro lado que la unión europea está
haciendo un esfuerzo decidido para
impulsar otras tecnologías energéticas
principalmente la eólica y la acción la
solar en este caso es importante
contextualizar que estas tecnologías
hablo de las renovables principalmente
eólica y solar no han podido dar la cara
por decirlo de alguna forma ya que este
satisfacer el incremento de la demanda
energética por las condiciones
climatológicas
particularmente severas que no les
permiten desempeñarse de forma
digamos de óptima pero en este sentido
creo que así hay una fuerza andrés para
dejar de depender de los combustibles de
suministro de gas natural de rosa y
hacer una cierta